are thinking on a different wavelength
you can't solve it
[Music]
can anybody explain what is happening in
this photograph
what is that oh is that a like some kind
of a vegetable
that kind of looks yeah it's a preserved
human being mummy baby it's a mommy baby
why is the head so big though it looks
like a mummy baby
I hope it's not a mommy baby
it's not a mommy baby looks like a
mushroom but it is definitely definitely
a mummified remains of a human whoa why
uh and it's in a delivery man's bag uh
it's like a doordash style bag that's
[__] up Oh I thought that was
sunbathing
The Mummy was sunbathing no like what it
looked like to me is somebody
um made like a oh like they're drying it
out like a shrine kind of thing because
they like to keep this baby like oh
you're still alive even though you did
baby and they're like baby you want some
slime that is so dark so then they put
they put it outside oh that's what she
meant that's their little uh
what do you call it like a little Cabana
like an area they got their little you
know that crazy person would do that I
was like the Mommy needs some sun yeah
so police in Peru have seized this
mummified human believed to be between
600 and 800 years old whoa from a former
26 year old food delivery man
The Mummy I know you guys are looking at
me like what the [__] yeah exactly crazy
this mummy was found nestled in this
isothermal bag that the man named Julio
Caesar burmejo had once used to deliver
food to people's homes Vermejo has been
arrested and will remain a detention
while investigators delve further into
the strange case but this guy claims
that this mummy is his spiritual
girlfriend that's [__] up okay that's
[__] up I mean how did he get that 600
year old mummy though so he claims to
have cared for this mummy who uh he
calls Juanita
30 years after his father brought it
home oh so it's like been passed down so
his father's an archaeologist that stole
it he's dead I don't think his dad's
archaeologist I don't think so dude
Indiana Holmes dude he's got a bunch of
little brushes that he uses like hey
Junior
come over here but he brings it around
in one of those bags it's freaking nasty
in an interview [__] Junior you ever
see anything like this before
that's just [__]
it's at least like 500 years old at
least
this is where what's
uh this is in uh Peru
I don't know the accents he said Mexican
it is I just love their food
go ahead continue he stops that [__] at
least at least can I tell you something
Japanese about Peru what
please let me tell you this that back at
funeral Japan
a little bit later before later
one of their presidents was Japanese
Japanese guy born in Peru they're like
we need something different they're like
all of our Peruvian presidents they've
been too corrupt we need someone new and
this guy was like a he was like a fifth
grade teacher and so they're they're a
sweet little couple and they're like you
know what the Japanese improved they're
good Farmers we could trust them there
are they're they're they're one of us
and so so he got elected the first
[__] thing he did when he
became
president is he created a straight up
kill Squad he developed in their own
Commandos right these assassination
groups that would go into the jungle and
kill the Communists like opposing wow um
yeah like totally violating these like
laws out there and then so once he got
caught for that and Corruption and all
this other stuff he just ran away to
Japan he's not even a Japanese citizen
he was born in Peru and he just seeped
Asylum there and and that was it and
they didn't extract him no he just ran
away and they gave him Asylum damn yeah
Japanese people are wild and when you
see this guy he looks like a nerd dude
he doesn't look like a guy that will
create a Commando kill Squad and go out
into the jungle and kill communist
terrorists yeah
he looks like a little [__] he looks
like a kind of guy if you backhand his
ass he'll fall on the ground and tell
you sorry
yeah you had a little surprised by your
like understanding and knowledge of
Japanese anything in random spots of the
world well I'm American so I had to find
some way to connect to my
so uh in an interview with other
reporters he describes how the mummy
sleeps beside him in his bedroom uh
adding that he takes great care of it he
says I take care of her I mean he's like
bragging about it it's like my spiritual
girlfriend the mummified remains are
thought to be a pre-hispanic relic and
an adult male individual oh Virginia duh
he's gay dude
oh my God presumably from the Eastern
Area puno the region the Peruvian Andes
some 1300 kilometers uh southeast of
Lima
so wow a specialist of the ministry has
stated that the mummy is uh is of a man
who is at least 45 years old and should
be referred to as Juan rather than
Juanita
dang dude had it all wrong and the body
was found wrapped in bandages in the
fetal position that's fun how big is it
it's 45 years old no 600 to 800 years
old believed it was no 45 though it was
a 45 year old man oh yeah when he died
yeah yeah but they shrunk him
over time yeah they get smaller right I
think I think in Joe's head it's still a
baby that's Sunday there that's a baby
but you know it probably got a lot
smaller over time as as a mummified
thing yeah they get like they reduce in
size can you imagine them like he likes
to sleep with his girlfriend right
they're sleeping he goes no I can't do
that I'm a virgin and then she's like
she's like
that's the role play that they have with
each other shut up I'm a virgin we're
not married yet and she goes nah but
like we can be because we're like Spirit
lovers he goes what you mean yeah if
we're Spirit lovers we're married
through Spirits it doesn't matter what
the real world says he goes that means
we command love and then he's like
kissing and [__] right and afterwards
her mouth falls off he gets this news it
was a 45 year old man and he's like
I'm gay
he lost his virginity to a 45 year old
man yeah
it's probably worth it like 645 years
statutory my boy
Juanita you're not who I thought you
were
you think he's just like yeah I'm gonna
call her Juanita and then he's just like
I'm just gonna go with it
for for the next 30 Years this must have
been passed down a lot of generations
then huh
I don't know I mean I mean like it's so
weird dude and I found a mummified
remain of anything obviously I don't
know if I would take it home to pass
down to my child that's because you're
not a good dad this is why I think the
homeless problem in La is unsolvable
because of this please explain how does
that connect bro just wait because wait
and I hope it connects to the Japanese
guy Pedro [__] San Pedro and all skid
row they're filled with [__]
like this
oh [__] that's my new girlfriend you
know it's like that's how do you solve
okay what are people's brains are
thinking on a different wavelength you
can't solve it yeah that's true that's
true crap like these people Jason these
people are like okay cool they're in
Peru so you're not viewing them as
homeless people you're viewing them as
like Peruvian citizens and he has a
normal job he's just delivering doordash
yeah you're saying they're just crazy
but if you but they're the exact same
character types as I've seen all over La
so you think we should just give the
skid row people a bunch of
I think
send them to Peru right in I don't think
that's in the budget for the government
I'd rather trade mummy dude than
homeless dudes because at least mummy
dude is doing doordash that's true with
a body in the bag yeah but it's 600
years old no one's missing them
no I mean I don't want my food with a
body in the bag delivered in the same
thing that's his girlfriend that's a boy
that's a significant other bro she's
gonna ride a shotgun while he's
delivering you know I am seeing the
pattern here the pattern in a lot of our
videos is like how we always talk about
like no matter what the context somehow
joking connected to Japan yeah and I'm
also announcing the pattern of
regardless of the contacts somehow bar
can complain about the homelessness
which is why you need to move
see this is why the people of skid row
are gonna be homeless forever
I'll checks out
if a mommy is that old right it's been
so dried up to where all the bacteria
and everything died anyway really so
what do you why do you care why am I
complaining that the mummies in the in
the Food Bag yeah why what if the mummy
what if the mommy help him why don't we
have enough money to send homeless
people to Peru send them there the
homeless problem is a problem in L.A
when I when I first
when I first got here to La I thought it
was going to be you know land of you
palm trees beaches beautiful women
that's what the postcards say
we do have all three of those yes and a
homeless guy jacking off though we don't
have that yeah we didn't put that in the
postcard right right he might be jacking
off onto the postcard yeah collecting
diarrhea in a bucket and I just I just
as I was you know as an Uber was just
driving past the neighborhoods I was
like oh my God yeah like these towns are
pretty cool and it's funny because he's
from New York he's from a city city and
he goes we have homeless people but not
like this not like that it's different
it's different yeah today I I saw this
homeless lady just jump on
it was like uh uh you know those metal
gates yeah uh and she just jumps on top
of it like Spiderman wow I'm casually
walking she jumps and looks at me it's
like Spider-Man
I gotta stop walking to this
neighborhood that's my gym I gotta go
but do you think if she jumped on it
looked at anyone like this
and something came out
to play along
I was I was eating next to your
neighborhood one time and then there was
this guy a homeless guy he had his stuff
and he was like asking for money for
food and it was this nice little couple
this lady she was like okay what do you
want to order and then so he um you know
he ordered some food to go and he goes
ma'am you are so nice
let me give you a show and then and then
everyone was like a show
and then she goes no it's okay goes no I
need to do this and he pulls out his
like Boombox right and he goes like
we're so the restaurant was out here
there's like a the eating area on the
side of the road like in Thai town and
this was during covet so like they even
brought out a part of the parking lot
and the street where people could dine
outside right so we're outside and
everyone's watching like what is this
dude about to do he goes into the middle
of the road and then he [__] puts on
music and he starts slowly pulling down
his pants and underneath he has like
some tight red ladies underwear and he's
all like doing a seductive dance and
then I was like this is the show he had
to perform
[Laughter]
was it a good show though worth it it
was it wasn't forget it was a very
sexual confident man yeah but it was
very unnecessary but he wanted to put on
a show as a as a way of thank you so I
see why you should move to Vegas Anthony
that's why you should move here you get
a show for a meal dude
[Music]
foreign